[Music]
how could a moth possibly come out on
top in a dog fight with a bat a new
study shows that Mars aren't exactly
pushovers when pitted against their
nightly tormentors researchers believe
one of the reasons silk moths in the
Saturnian family stand a fighting chance
might have something to do with the
shape of their wings when it comes to
hunting moths and other flying insects
the most powerful tool in a bats arsenal
is its ability to use sonar to pick
targets out of the air however
researchers have found that the long
elaborate tails on silk moths hind wings
help to deflect the bats own arm like a
built-in decoy researchers found four
distinct wing types related to a silk
moths ability to escape bat attacks to
test the effectiveness of each wing type
they altered the profiles of three types
of silk moths to resemble the wing
shapes it faced off the modified moths
with big brown bats in a flight room and
captured the results on high-speed
cameras researchers found that the
larger the hind wing and longer the tail
the better the moths chances of escaping
bats on the hunt
since bats only eat a moths body and not
its wings that's what they look for when
hunting the tails offer multiple body
like targets tricking striking bats and
researchers say that the bats weren't
very effective at fighting away or on
the moths defense even after facing the
same types of hind wing shapes for
months bats still couldn't tell the
difference between a tasty moth morsel
and its tail driven decoy score one for
the underdog or moth
[Music]